[Música]
quando eu era mais novo
lembro com muita qualidade de passar
muitas das minhas férias de verão com os
meus avós numa pequena aldeia no
interior do país lembrou particularmente
muitas vezes ficam eu vou à noite
simplesmente observar o céu estrelado
e para mim é um rapaz da cidade não
ficasse plantadas pela quantidade e
diversidade de pontos brilhantes no céu
e acho que foi começou minha paixão pelo
espaço
o meu crer explorar recentemente tive a
oportunidade de sentir como seria
explorar o planeta nem particular
marta martins hoje o planeta frio
deserto era fina e principalmente
dióxido carbono nada amigável a vida
nós temos que no passado marquinhos
perto assim as cenas da equipe uma
temperatura mais amena uma história mais
densa ou seja tinha todos os
ingredientes que poderiam levar a vida
sem terra em condições humilhantes a
vida surgiu responder à questão será que
havia surgido em marketing e surgiu será
que existe porque queremos ir a marte
queremos misturar já temos rovers robô
em marte grafias da superfície do
planeta
isso é uma máquina construir na terra
enviamos milhões e milhões de
quilômetros e conseguiu entrar naquele
pequeno pontos brilhantes no céu em
vídeo fotografia da superfície do
planeta enfim no celf superfície do
planeta
você vem do outro mundo
então o próximo passo seria enviar os
primeiros humanos marketing
sabemos que os humanos juntamente com
robôs são melhor maneira de furar um
ambiente
mas martin para os seus desafios a
começar pela distância ou fora de uma
missão que teria cerca de dois anos
nunca tivemos uma missão ao espaço tão
grande nem quando fomos à lua transforma
num atraso na comunicação ou seja quando
enviamos uma mensagem de marta chegará à
terra dependendo da órbita entre 8 e 20
minutos
pensar em nossa última conversa
telefónica
certamente precisamos mostrar ao brasil
existe uma solução mesma maneira como
conseguimos já a tentar resolver esse
desafio já a pensar com as melhores
soluções ea seção missões análogas
realmente agora perguntar se a opção
missões aulas
vamos responder essa pergunta lançar
aqui um desafio
essas duas imagens são dois planetas
diferentes uma na terra a outra e
marketing e quero ver se conseguem
identificar quem é que acha que marina
está à esquerda uma esquerda e quem é
que acha que marina está à direita
cada vez mais parecem achar que o marido
está à direita
bem mais trabalho
mas a questão não é tanto qual é qual a
questão é que existem sítios na terra
que de fato de semana muita margem do
ponto de vista geológico minero lógico
emissões anual das comissões cada vez
mais sítios basicamente para simular
martins para testar as tecnologias
queremos vender a marca os procedimentos
e ver com as funções que melhor
funcionam nesses ambientes em 2015
foi só assinava como alguém que está
assinado e treinados para estas missões
análogas mais de 100 candidatos a mais
de 100 das provas individuais por ser um
dos escolhidos e desde então tem
treinado muito nosso trabalho passa
pensamento por utilizar esta foto da
princesa os livros de josé
então é um fato bastante compacto todo
um sistema complexo com diversos
sensores de temperatura uma edição da
competição
além do fato um complexo portuguesa que
nos mantém vivos um sistema de
comunicação que lhes permite comunicar
com a nossa base é cerca de 50 quilos é
nada fácil e precisa bastante treinar
com imagem não muito atraente passa por
estar dentro deste fato dentro mas
também fora saber quais os componentes
do fato saber como montar sabia tudo
sobre o fato
apesar daquelas luvas já deve ter
reparado trouxe comigo e se quiser no
fim da sessão para analisar estas duas
são as mesmas luvas com as quais
treinamos e alguns vôos e treinaram que
experimentaram antes desta apresentação
e sabem não é muito fácil
um dos momentos mais marcantes do meu
treino foi a primeira vez que este
evento fato momento em que fecha o
capacete
vamos atender do fato para viver os
sonhos fica abafado
o ritmo cardíaco aumenta é como que
somos transportados para outro mundo é
uma sensação uma sensação muito especial
que gostaria que a gente estava
experimentais algum dia
então este ano
uma missão nos desertos do far humana
durante o mês foram desvinculadas de
qualquer civilização - pouca comunicação
com a nossa família e amigos estavam
diferentes tecnologias diferentes equipe
- e aprendemos o que poderia funcionar
em marketing
estamos johns ver se a tecnologia como
impressão 3d 3d acho que será uma
tecnologia crucial para marte como deve
imaginar qualquer quilograma queremos
tirar da terra enviava para marte tem o
seu custo aumenta a complexidade da
missão
então não tem sentido de levar todas as
peças suplentes que possamos imaginar
que possam partilhar alguma vez não
temos uma estratégia que permite
imprimir à medida que as peças despertam
e podemos então já os nossos temas do
mesmo ponto de vista
a comida também não terá sentido do voto
vai comigo dois anos conosco desde o
início temos que olhar para alternativas
que façam crescer e comida é marca seja
uma atribuição sustentável ao investir
em tecnologias e claro usamos bastante o
fato de experiências entre o fato eo
pensamento do ponto de vista geológico
aprender qual é o ambiente que temos à
nossa volta a procurar vestígios de vida
tudo isso está bastante bem no início de
setembro fazer minha própria self é
marte mas precisa haver alguns problemas
começando pela temperatura temperaturas
que eram duas voltas para àquela altura
do ano era normais e o nosso faltava ter
alguns problemas mas a temperatura
dentro do fato de 40 graus
se imaginar em 50 que os 40 graus não só
não é agradável como pode ser perigoso
então a solução passou por ele nas horas
mais três dias do dia mas o fim de tarde
às vezes até a cabana as atividades à
noite não significa que estamos a ter
menos tempo para a missão estamos a
ficar um pouco atrasados nos nossos
objetivos e em cima disso com o tempo
total de idéia só com uma marquise
tempestade de areia que impossibilitam
qualquer ação no exterior estão mais
atrasados e estamos a ficar
estamos a aproximar-nos nos últimos dias
de missão e tempo todo não se embora e
no fim apenas um dia para fazer os
nossos objetivos finais
nós temos que fazer estamos a ficar sem
tempo infelizmente temos o nosso centro
de controle na terra
neste caso estava na áustria eu só acho
que nos ajuda a purificar o nosso dia
assegura que a atividade de fazer e como
melhor fazê las e plantamos o que
fazemos estamos a ficar sem tempo
o que vamos fazer e 11 anos aprendem a
idéia da mãe faz um som fazendo três
dias num dia a dia de todos tanto eu
como meu colega carta que está no meio
do deserto fazer o máximo possível
tentar conseguir todos os objetivos
finais os ombros dores nas costas
durante todo o mês da missão sentir o
calor do fato das formas crescendo daqui
eu posso mais
nesta foto não parece que estamos indo
mais rápido conseguimos com 50 quilos
mais a equipe - não dá tem muito mais
depressa e que vamos conseguir nossa
primeira missão com sucesso
cumprimos todos os objetivos os nossos
índices tiveram todos os dados que
precisavam então eu por ser um sucesso
ainda perdemos muitos que tecnologias
funcionam melhor em marketing lembra
outro lado lembrando também da minha
infância ver o mesmo céu estrelado na
infância e pensava mesmo a cumprir o seu
sonho está a conseguir isso é algo
realmente extraordinário contribuir na
exploração espacial realmente
extraordinário mas também de ver o pôr
do sol no deserto e que irão sobrar é
realmente algo espetacular
principalmente após uma tempestade de
areia
o céu fica no vermelho vivo como nunca
vi o espetáculo eu não pensar como será
o produção e marketing
as fotos são de marte e é um caso
isolado e sim devido ao américa com uma
luz fraca na atmosfera mais fina do mato
durante o dia temos um céu informado
mas o pôr do sol é de fato eu sou um
pouco ao contrário temos na terra ao
curioso e certeza que os primeiros
produtos de marketing abriram este facto
de o pôr do sol da mesma maneira mas
mais do que isso
acho que depois de se pôr do sol nas
horas mais tarde era no céu mas eram as
estrelas e procuram é o pequeno ponto
azul que a terra é pensar na família na
casa dos amigos esperar o melhor
a fragilidade de um ponto azul também da
sua infância
o sonho de criança de 5 anos estava a
mensagem é que não deixem os vossos
sonhos de criança de cinco anos para
trás flor em sonning descubra
[Aplausos]